Acting is a profession that requires a lot
of versatility and a willingness to test boundaries.
Often, this bravery pays off with a critically
acclaimed performance that's lauded for years
or even becomes cinematic history.
Sometimes, however, it results in a complete
nightmare for everyone involved.
Ellen Page's bad joke
"Are you honestly and truly going to prom
with Katrina De Voort?"
"... Hi."
"Mia just said that you were gonna go with
her."
Juno was a critical darling upon its release
in 2007, but actress Ellen Page thinks the
indie comedy has one really big flaw... and
we're not talking about that hamburger phone
… or the overly stylized dialogue.
"Silencio, old man…
Look, I just drank my weight in Sunny D, and
I gotta go pronto!"
The actress regrets Juno's joke about potentially
naming her baby "Madison."
"Isn't that, like, a little gay?"
Page told Bustle that the joke didn't register
with her at the time, but now that she's older,
she really wishes it hadn't happened.
It's worth noting that Page came out as gay
in 2014, and she's become a vocal advocate
for LGBTQ rights.
In fact, when Page performed a staged reading
of Juno for Planned Parenthood in 2017, she
skipped that line entirely.
Denzel Washington is all wet
Based on the 1980s TV show of the same name,
The Equalizer stars Denzel Washington as Robert
McCall, a widower who works at a hardware
store when he's not busy killing bad guys.
In the film's climax, McCall lures some murderous
Russian gangsters to his place of employment…
where an explosion sets off the store's sprinkler
system.
Looks boss, right?
Well, Washington told CinemaBlend he quickly
got real tired of being so damn wet.
"By that third day, at about eleven at night,
after about a thireen hour day, I disagreed."
Still looks pretty boss, though.
Margot Robbie gets messy
Actress Margot Robbie had a pretty bad time
making Suicide Squad.
First of all, her character Harley Quinn wore
skimpy outfits that made her feel self-conscious.
"You're welcome."
And she kept accidentally poking herself with
her spiky gold bangles.
"Harley Quinn, nice to meet cha."
But when The Washington Post asked Robbie
what scene was her least favorite, she had
an answer at the ready.
She absolutely hated filming that scene where
Quinn throws herself into a vat of white ooze.
Robbie says she was utterly repulsed because
the nasty stuff kept getting into her ears
and nose.
"I couldn't breathe, and I tried to open my
eyes, and it would glaze over my eyeballs,
and I could only see white.
It was horrible."
Chris Hemsworth: Shirts and skins
Actor Chris Hemsworth isn't too thrilled about
undressing on-screen these days.
"Sorry I Tased you!"
He was perfectly fine being shirtless in the
first Thor film, but increasingly got annoyed
at those gratuitous scenes starring his abs.
When Thor: The Dark World rolled around, director
Joss Whedon insisted he strip down after a
big battle sequence.
Speaking with MTV News, Hemsworth admitted
he was hesitant.
"And he said, 'Chris, take your shirt off'...
And I said, 'Well, I don't know…
What's the why?
What are we doing?"
The issue came up again during Thor: Ragnarok...
And the shirt came off again.
Hemsworth told Access Hollywood he was relieved
he could keep his shirt on during the fifth
Thor film.
But director Taika Waititi felt the film needed
some eye-candy.
"And then Tai came midway through shooting,
come up and said, 'I think we need to put
some bums on seats, I think we need to get
the shirt off,' and I was like, 'No, they
don't want to see that.'"
They did, though.
Josh Brolin: God killer
It's fun playing the biggest bad guy in the
universe.
Just ask Josh Brolin.
He crushed it as Thanos in Avengers: Infinity
War.
And he reportedly really enjoyed tearing The
Hulk a new one.
But Brolin says he wasn't altogether pleased
about having to kill Loki.
According to Brolin, actor Tom Hiddleston
was obsessed with getting Loki's last scene
just right, so filming became quite the bittersweet
bummer.
Brolin told USA Today:
"Tom was so vulnerable at that moment.
So choking him out wasn't the most fun thing
I have ever done."
Is it possible Loki will somehow be resurrected,
much like a certain Game of Thrones character
before him?
"Shhhh."
Kurt Russell's hateful fate
"I don't feel so good."
Directed by Quentin Tarantino, The Hateful
Eight was a lighting rod for hot takes and
angry opinions.
But music lovers probably had the best reason
to hate the film... especially since Kurt
Russell destroyed a guitar that turned out
to be a priceless antique.
"Music time's over."
"Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!"
Russell thought the guitar was a prop, but
it was actually an instrument from the 1860s…
and worth over $40,000.
The incident really shook up Leigh, as she'd
fallen in love with the antique, and Russell
was devastated by what he'd done.
"I'm already regretting this."
Speaking to Billboard, Leigh explained that
Russell "felt terrible" when he discovered
his mistake:
"When he found out, his eyes literally welled
up.
It ended up being great for the scene, but
very sad for the guitar, and for my guitar
teacher, and for me."
Zoey Deutch's pizza problem
It's rare that a romantic comedy comes along
and breathes new life into the genre.
But when Set It Up hit Netflix, critics were
delighted by the tale of two employees trying
to get their bosses to hook up.
Starring Zoey Deutch and Glen Powell, the
film takes a predictable turn when the two
matchmakers fall in love themselves.
In the film's most celebrated scene, the two
coworkers share a late-night pizza, which
sparks their romance.
"This is the best meal I've ever had."
Unfortunately for Deutch, filming the scene
wasn't exactly romantic.
That's because she devoured four entire pies
while shooting that scene, and threw up halfway
through the shoot.
And then she had to get very close to Glen
Powell in order to finish the shoot.
She told Hello Giggles,
"I think [he] looks at me in a very different
light."
Fifty Shades of gross
Critics weren't the only ones who found Fifty
Shades of Grey alarmingly unsexy.
Based on the runaway bestseller book of the
same name, the 2015 film stars Jamie Dornan
as the snooziest sadist ever … and Dakota
Johnson as his willing slave.
"I need you to show me what you want to do
to me.
Punish me.
Show me how bad it can be."
Unfortunately, filming all those bondage,
domination, and torture scenes could be pretty
bad.
Johnson spent hours tied up, blindfolded,
and pretending to be struck by a whip.
She told Time magazine,
"It's really hot—not in a steamy, sexual
way.
It's just sweaty and it's not very comfortable."
She said the sex scenes were so taxing, she
started thinking, "Okay, let's just get this
over with."
Coincidentally, that's exactly what we were
thinking halfway through Fifty Shades of Grey.